you got this wacky dude he's a wacky  okay he's a wacky dude and and we can  all agree also that sometimes when  you're mentally paranoid you will pick  up a grab bag of conspiracies and wild  ideas so this guy is a Berkeley nudist  he's lgbtq but he still thinks the  election was stolen so he he's not a  political you can't place him on the  Spectrum he's a paranoid right yes  somehow he figures out and I don't know  how he did this but he figures out how  to get into the Pelosi house right he  gets in I think what happens is because  he's a nut he starts engaging Paul  Pelosi right but he doesn't threaten him  he doesn't threaten him because that  explains the NBC report Paul Pelosi  comes to the door first of all Paul  Pelosi does not tell the cops he's being  attacked he doesn't say that he says  come do a wellness check on me right he  knows the guy's name he goes the guy's  name is David and he's a friend